Pocahontas and jasmine are two Disney
Princesses that have the strength to
challenge their father's expectations
but which one would be victorious in a
battle between them watch until the end
to find out which princess would be the
last one standing Pocahontas is and
Jasmine's place in the history of Disney
princesses Pocahontas and jasmine are
right next to each other in the Disney
Princess Kanin bands were first
introduced to Princess Jasmine when the
movie Aladdin came out in 1992 then we
met Pocahontas in the 1995 movie of the
same name and these two strong women
have lots in common so much so we
thought it would be fun to pit them
against each other in a classic Disney
Princess faceoff first off let's give a
little context to their place in the
history of Disney films jasmine and
Pocahontas are part of the Renaissance
period of Disney movies this era lasted
from around 1989 to 1999 the princess
movies that came out during this time
showed a shift from the princesses of
the Disney Golden Age Snow White
Cinderella and Sleeping Beauty were all
passively waiting for their prince to
arrive but the renaissance princesses
were much more independent minded women
and that's where we can draw a lot of
parallels between these two characters
Pocahontas is and Jasmine's similarities
like Ariel and Belle before them and
move on after these two Disney
Renaissance princesses aren't toeing the
line Pocahontas and jasmine aren't doing
what they're told and letting the men
lead the way and in this way they're
totally typical of their era they both
defy their fathers wishes they're both
strong-minded these young women want to
decide their own futures they certainly
do not want to be told what to do by
their powerful dads like whom they
should marry but despite all of these
parallels there are some important
differences that give us an idea of who
would defeat the other let's start with
the 18 year old daughter of Chief
Powhatan Pocahontas Pocahontas is
strengths from the outset we see that
Pocahontas is daring and brave she
flings herself down a waterfall after
all she does this again when she shows
John Smith the wonders of the natural
world during the colors of the wind
sequence speaking of John when
Pocahontas comes face to face with him
she stands
she doesn't cower and when she's
secretly watching him poblanas proves
how stealthy she is creeping quietly
unseen this daredevil bravery and South
would serve her well in a battle with
Jasmine but they're not her only
strength surely her most heroic moment
is when she throws herself in front of
John just as her father is about to end
his life though ganas is willing to
perform the ultimate act of valor she's
willing to sacrifice herself for the
sake of others when John and kocoum
fight Pocahontas also tries to stop them
physically if she's up for getting
involved in such intimidating fight
scenes then she'd surely have the
bravery to battle jasmine
so far it looks like Pocahontas would be
a strong opponent against jasmine
however jasmine has a crucial quality
that could well tip the scales in her
favor let's find out the extent of
Jasmine's strengths Before we jump to
any conclusions Jasmine's strengths
jasmine has one significant advantage
over Pocahontas and that's her strategy
skills
Pocahontas doesn't succeed with her plan
to bring peace until the very end of the
film so you might say that Pocahontas is
tactical thinking isn't her strongest
suit however jasmine is definitely
cunning there are multiple times when
she manages to outwit others like when
she realizes that she's met Prince Olly
already and he's not quite who he says
he is when they go on they're a whole
new world magic carpet ride she tricks
Aladdin into admitting that they've met
before by mentioning Abu fireworks then
later she distracts Jafar by pretending
to find him attractive in her attempt to
help the lad and grab the genie lamp
Jasmine is also confident enough in her
position of power as the Sultan's
daughter to throw her royal weight
around she does this with guards when
they try to capture Aladdin in the
marketplace that's during her time
undercover as a peasant we also see her
ability to learn quickly when she's
hanging out with Aladdin in his street
rat reality
she even comments on what a fast learner
she is when she manages to use the stick
to effortlessly jump over the gap
however she also exposes one of her key
weaknesses when she's undercover in
Agrabah market keep watching to discover
what that is first let's explore
Pocahontas weaker points the next
question is do Pocahontas is faults
outweighed
Jasmin's flaws or is it the other way
around Pocahontas is weakness is a
significant part of winning a battle is
your attitude towards conflict and
Pocahontas is definitely not in favor of
fighting in fact many would go so far as
to call her a pacifist being a peace
lover is by no means a weakness quite
the opposite in fact
but when we're thinking about Pocahontas
in the context of a battle we can't help
but think she just wouldn't be able to
bring herself to actually fight the
Warriors in her village certainly know
how to use a bow and arrow and tomahawks
but poke honest doesn't bear arms
herself she doesn't use weapons at all
so that leads us to ask what about
jasmine what are her key flaws when it
comes to the fight Jasmine's weaknesses
we love both Pocahontas and Jasmine but
let's get real for a moment about
Jasmine she ends up in the typical
Disney Golden Age damsel in distress
role although we were planned to
distract a fire proved how tactical she
is it didn't work he realized her plot
and conjured her into a sand timer and
there she was her time running out quite
literally while she passively had to
wait for Aladdin to save her that's not
necessarily what you'd expect of a
victorious battler another one of
Jasmine's weaknesses when it comes to
doing battle is that she's pretty naive
about the real world we see this in the
marketplace when she innocently hands an
apple to a little child you'd better be
able to pay for that she has no idea you
have to pay for things or what the
punishment is for stealing would she
have the street smarts to be Pocahontas
if they faced off it seems like Jasmine
and Pocahontas are pretty evenly matched
at this point but what if their battle
wasn't a one-on-one fight but involve
their squads too Pocahontas a squad
Pocahontas follows in the Disney
Princess tradition of having animal
sidekicks so the question is how much
help would they be to Pocahontas in a
battle against jasmine let's start with
her friend Miko the raccoon to be
brutally honest Miko wouldn't be much
help at all
the raccoon spends his time looking for
food and eventually making friends with
governor Ratcliffe Stog Percy being
greedy and friendly aren't really the
top qualities you look for in fighting
companions as for flit the hummingbird
he'd be more useful
he's fiercely loyal and takes any
opportunity to defend Pocahontas
we see this with his aggressive behavior
on the first meeting of John Smith
you can't fault his loyalty or his
willingness to attack but he's so small
he can't do huge amounts of damage the
final member of Pocahontas new squad
isn't an animal companion but a nature
spirit guide grandmother willow is very
wise and advises Pocahontas which is
helpful in tactical planning and she can
also help physically as we see when she
lifts her roots to trip up the British
settlers Ben and lon
Jasmine squad Jasmine squad includes her
animal sidekick Raja the tiger we can
also count the genie as a squad member
plus Aladdin's monkey Abu if it's cold
hard fierce power you're looking for
then Jasmine's pet tiger has to be right
up there
Raja loyally protects his owner and is
aggressive to anyone who doesn't please
her like the long list of suitors that
try to win her hand in marriage as well
as attacking them he's fierce towards
Aladdin in the beginning - then there's
Abu
Aladdin's monkey who also joins forces
with Jasmine to help defeat Jafar given
that he spent lots of time helping
Aladdin steal food he could be useful
for stealing Jasmine's opponent's
weapons Abu could also come in very
handy for getting out of a tight fit as
he helps Aladdin escape from jail
finally there's the genie at the lamp
yep having a wish-granting buddy on your
side could certainly help in a battle
but let's not forget that genie has
given his freedom at the end of the film
so when it comes to which Squad would be
the most useful we think Jasmine takes
this one but what about the princess's
other allies Pocahontas is allies we've
saved Pocahontas his greatest advantage
to last and that's her relationship with
the natural world she is at one with
nature and uses its message and powers
to help her not only does she listen to
the winds to guide her decisions but she
also uses it to physically help her the
wind and it's spirits help Pocahontas to
leap over mountainous crevasses as she
races to save John given that the forces
of nature carry her through space she
could even use them as a gateway device
stop or move quickly from dangerous
situations that would definitely come in
handy in a battle against jasmine she
also understands wild animals and has a
connection with them from bears wolves
and Eagles to otters and herons when you
connect so deeply with the entire
natural world around you
you're pretty much unbeatable Jasmine's
allies Jasmine might not be able to sing
with all the voices of the mountains or
feet with all the colors of the wind
like Pocahontas can but she also has
other allies in addition to her animal
friends and the most useful of all of
these is the magic carpet anyone who's
going into a tense situation knows they
need an exit plan like a gateway car and
what better way to make a swift exit
then by a flying carpet as the daughter
of the Sultan jasmine also has the
palace guards at her disposal she could
order them to help her defeat whatever
enemy she had to face but we saw how the
bungled various scenarios from capturing
Aladdin to seizing too far so perhaps
they wouldn't be much of a match against
Pocahontas and the power of the natural
world we reckoned this round goes to
Pocahontas as she has the edge over
Jasmine when it comes to useful allies
so now we've analyzed the princess's
strengths weaknesses squads and allies
it's time to decide who would win in a
face-off make your predictions right now
before we announce our victor Pocahontas
versus Jasmine so now it's time to find
out which Disney princess would Trump
the other we know you'll want to defend
her favorite girl and it sure is a close
call but all in all we think Pocahontas
would be victorious that's because she
has the whole of nature on her side
[Music]
she's brave stealthy in the daredevil
and she's willing to sacrifice
everything for those she loves Jasmine
put up a good fight however she is brave
too a tactical thinker and as a fierce
Tiger to defend her so she wasn't
trailing far behind but if we're being
totally honest neither of these
characters are the fiercest of the
Disney Princesses yes they know their
own minds and are strong-willed but
they're lovers not fighters so all of
the other Disney Princesses can breathe
a sigh of relief that they don't have to
fear either Pocahontas or jasmine so
there you have it guys
Pocahontas is the winner before you go
let us know in the comments below if you
agree with us and sound off about which
of the Disney Princesses you think would
be the most intimidating in a battle and
that's it for the video if you love
everything Disney make sure to get
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]